[музика]
Вітаю це програма У фокусі Європа я Лара
баба Лола раді що ви приєднались до нас
апокаліптичний шторм так люди в Італії
описують сильну повінь яка зруйнувала
частину країни
сильні зливи пройшли по всій країні
особливо сильно постраждала північ
Італії десятка тисяч людей залишились
без даху над головою їхні будинки на
крило совами ґрунту дороги
розмилоповинями більше десятка людей
загинуло
основний удар повені прийняв на себе
регіон Емілія Романія Всього за 36 годин
випала піврічна норма опадів
рідше які відчувають жителі змішуються з
гнівом у муніципалітеті модільяна
зростає критика в бік політиків адже
багато хто вважає що наслідки повені
могли бути менш серйозними таку думку
поділяє фруктовий фермер Андреа маландрі
будівельні проекти порушили баланс його
вразливого регіону адже через них
заасфальтовують ґрунт і його поглинаюча
здатність зменшується це створило
Ідеальний шторм дозволило силам природи
показати свою могутність
Андреа меландрі непокоїться за свої
фруктові дерева його Ферма площею 25
гектарів була повністю затоплена якщо
вода не висохне у найближчі дні мала
Андрій може втратити весь урожай ківі
яблуки персиків а це понад півмільйона
євро Каже він
психіатр
щодо майбутнього
це наше життя якщо це все загине ми
втратимо все
для таких фермерів як
меландрікатастрофічні повені просто
чергова загроза
Італія вважається особливо вразливою до
кліматичних змін останніми роками каже
він йому доводилося боротися з посухою
градом торнадо а останнім часом із
заморозками
раніше я хвилювався через сильний холод
Тепер я більше боюся повеней
тоді теж була невизначеність але це ніщо
у порівнянні з тим що зараз
але не лише Кліматичні зміни зіграли
свою роль у нещодавній повені яка
затопила цілі міста із причинила потоки
бруду та уламків що мчали вниз із
апеннінських гір
деякі з причин здається мають ці
місцевий характер Емілія Романія один із
найбільш вразливих регіонів Італії Якщо
говорити про повені та суви в основному
через багаторічне неконтрольоване
будівництво на алювіальних рівнинах
унаслідок якого цілі райони і без того
схильні до повеней повністю покриваються
асфальтом понад 200 тисяч гектарів землі
було заасфальтовано зокрема й ліси
кажуть такі експерти як Габріель боліні
річки втискаються в дедалі вище тому що
береги щоб звільнити місце для будинків
промисловості та сільського господарства
Ми повинні змінити Цей підхід
5 років тому регіональний уряд прийняв
амбітний законопроект Про нульове
споживання землі але за словами боліні
його так і не вдалося реалізувати зони
підвищеного ризикуповані вже давно
нанесені на карту синя лінія чітко
вказує де нічого не можна будувати але
їх ніхто не хотів слухати
коли я працював місцевий адміністрації
іноді приходили депутати і Просили мене
перенести лінію щоб дозволити їхнім
друзям і так далі будувати
у цьому і проблема
коли політика займається такими речами
вона не дбає про суспільні інтереси чи
інтереси майбутніх поколінь
величезні родючі землі Емілії романії
перетинає розгалужена іригаційна
інфраструктура
багато каналів і струмків тут вийшли з
берегів
метеоролог П'єр Луїджі ранзі каже що це
також частково пов’язано з тим що Італія
пережила два роки сильної посухи перед
цим стихійним лихом це означало що
догляд за водними шляхами і берегами
річок регіону не вважався пріоритетом
одна з речей яку ми повинні зробити це
реструктуризувати і пристосувати землю
до нового клімату ми повинні взяти на
себе відповідальність та інвестувати в
інфраструктуру яка може привести нас до
адаптації Нам доведеться адаптуватися
Очевидно в місті модільяна
початку травня коли пройшла перша хвиля
повеней тут було зафіксовано понад 200
сумів ґрунту у наслідок чого було
пошкоджено комунікаційні мережі дороги
та системи водопостачання місцева Влада
заявляє що хоча пріоритет це відбудова
Але такий стихійне лихо показує що це не
може бути просто звичайним бізнесом є
будинки які були побудовані там де їх не
повинно було бути прямо на траєкторії
потенційного суду ми маємо
відбудовуватися З повагою до природного
ландшафту і місцевого рельєфу
освоїв чергу фермер Андре меландрі не
знає як довго йому вдасться протриматися
під усе сильнішим натиском екстремальних
погодних явищ
бути фермером сьогодні стало майже
героїчною справою
якщо це те до чого нам доведеться
звикати то це буде важко
дійсно важко
У той час як Емілія Романія не
покладаючи рук бореться з наслідками
повені питання про те що посилило цю
трагедію що можна з неї винести звучить
усе голосніше
порушення природного балансу викликає
тривогу і в Албанії
будівельний бум у цій країні спричинив
дебати про комерцію та берегову лінію
колись Албанія була однією з найбідніших
країн Європи але зараз її економіка має
багато обіцяючи перспективи останні
кілька років туристична індустрія
зростає у геометричній прогресії це
призвело до масового будівництва В таких
місцях як ксаміл на албанській рів'єрі
тамтешні узбережжя приголомшливий
природний Рай Але там не завжди
дотримуються будівельних та екологічних
норм тепер незаймані краєвиди
перекриваються спокусою великих
прибутків
хаджі марку власник ресторану у бухті на
півдні Албанії
Він готується до туристичного сезону
незабаром прибудуть перші відвідувачі
Мені дуже подобається цей краєвид дуже
чиста вода дуже гарна і гарне сонце Мені
пощастило з цим місцем тому що тут свіжу
то вітряно
цю ділянку узбережжя називають
албанськими карибами багато прекрасних
пляжів приваблюють все більше і більше
туристів
ці знімки були зроблені влітку коли
регіон переповнений туристами
тусовщиками
марку насолоджується тишею і спокуєм
перед початком туристичного сезону
раніше він працював на грецькому острові
Корфу що знаходиться на іншому березі
моря Але у 2012 році повернувся до
рідної Албанії щоб заснувати власний
бізнес
тут працює близько 20 людей
туристичний сектор Албанії процвітає
це спричинило будівельний бум особливо
на узбережжі
професор Крісто каурі колишні Лісовий
інженер майже не впізнає узбережжі
Албанії
стічні води течуть прямо в море
весь цей бетон і залізо принесли нам ці
проблеми
це порушило баланс баланс між морем
піском і рослинами
офіційно заборонено будувати ближче 200
метрів від моря щоб захистити узбережжя
але тут у самілі будинки були побудовані
навіть посеред національного парку де
мешкають види що охороняються в державі
довелося їх знести каурій хвилюється за
свій рідний регіон Він збирається
зустрітися з очільницею ксаміля щоб
поділитися своїми проблемами за кілька
кілометрів Ми зустрічаємо німецьких
туристів які вже кілька тижнів в Албанії
вони сповнені позитивних відгуків про цю
країну Хоча і помітили масову забудову
Коли ви їдете вздовж узбережжя ви бачите
величезні готельні комплекси які будують
скрізь ймовірно без урахування природи
та оточення
не всі хочуть долучатися до цього
туристичного буму за 70 кілометрів на
північ денівського каваші керує
невеликим кемпінгом
більшість його постійних гостей шукають
тиші із спокою
ми маємо мало спільну з туристами які
хочуть проводити свої відпустку
квадратного бетонному номері
гості Тут цінують незайману природу і це
дуже важливо для бізнесу Кока ваші
усе повинно залишатися так як є але на
жаль це залежить не від нас
повернувшись до ксаміля професор каурі
зустрічається з міською головою
висловлюючи її своє занепокоєння
Ми повинні пояснити туристам і
відвідувачам як захистити цю природу
але в очільниці міста інші пріоритети
тут туризм основне джерело доходу
Я думаю що є ще достатньо місця для
будівництва
є достатньо вільної землі Її треба
використовувати для туризму
але природа крихка і незабаром Албанії
доведеться вирішити які напрямок обрати
тусовочний туризм як на ібіці чи більш
стійку форму туризму
Ріна в Україні кинула Цінь на
сепаратистський регіон Придністров'я він
відокремився від Молдови у 1990 році
коли розпався Радянський Союз але його
незалежність не визнана на міжнародному
рівні Придністров'я значною мірою про
кремлівське молдовани такі як Юрій
коцофан побоюється що їхню країну може
спіткати доля подібна до долі України
багато хто в Молдові хоче тісніших
зв'язків із заходом і Минулого року
країна подала заявку на членство в
Європейському Союзі
[музика]
[оплески]
столиця Молдови Кишинів 21 травня
десятки тисяч людей вийшли на мітинг на
підтримку вступу до Євросоюзу
багатьма з них також керує страх перед
російським вторгненням
Юрій куцофан один із них він знає що
таке воювати з російськими військами
разом зі своїми товаришами він намагався
захистити молдавську землю від
проросійських сепаратистів три
десятиліття тому він задумується над тим
чи Не доведеться йому знову іти на війну
[оплески]
уявляєте собі що це ціла країна Молдова
і Україна якщо Україна впаде Росія не
зупиниться на берегах Дністра
російські війська вже знаходяться на
території Молдови згідно із міжнародним
правом
ця частина річки Дністер відокремлює
Молдову від проросійської
сепаратистської держави на Східному
березі Придністров'я
Придністров'я відокремилось від Молдови
у 1990-х роках заморожена пострадянська
війна
кожен хто хоче відвідати цей регіон
повинен скористатися цим поромом по той
бік річки російські солдати стоять на
варті
Вони знаходяться тут уже 30 років
офіційно виконуючи миротворчу місію
Юрій коцефан зустрічає нас у кучієрах
одному з молдавських сіл на кордоні із
Придністров'я
на перший погляд усе виглядає спокійно
але для Юрія це не так
тут не було тихо з 1991 року поки на
лівому березі Дністра стоїть російська
армія А це місце знаходиться під
окупацією тут ніколи не буде миру
село кучієри розколоте у цій громаді
багато тих хто вважає що молдовський
уряд у Кишеневі нехто і їхніми
інтересами і відчувають прихильність до
Росії
ми абсолютно не проти Росії ми хочемо
мати тісні зв'язки з нею щоб допомагати
і підтримувати одне одного багато людей
ненавидять Путіна тому що мовляв він
розв'язує війни але насправді все
відбувається навпаки
хоч і єри отримують дешевий російський
газ благословення для багатьох у цьому
бідному регіоні
але для молоді дешевого газу недостатньо
щоб залишатися тут
третина населення виїхала
Крістіан теж збирається виїхати
у нас не так багато можливостей
Я хочу поїхати в іншу країну Але у нас
не так багато грошей
середній дохід до кучієрог становить
близько 250 євро на місяць
Крістіан ділить Цю кімнату з братом і
батьками
його мрії більше за їхню кімнату
я планую закінчити школу і вивчати
графічний дизайн
якщо все піде добре Я хотів би працювати
за кордоном у США
він стурбований адже якщо Україна
програє війну Придністров'я з ними Росія
може ще сильніше взяти під свій контроль
кочіяри
М
Я не дуже добре Почуваюся у суспільстві
яке підтримує лише руський мір
їх так багато і вони мені набридли
Я хотів би бачити інших людей які
мислять нормально
ніхто тут не хоче війни каже Крістіан
наприкінці але навіть у цьому маленькому
селі фронти розділилися
одні хочуть допомоги від Росії інші
сподіваються на членство в ЄС і багато
хто боїться що війна в сусідній Україні
може дуже скоро опинитися на їхньому
порозі
наслідки війни в Україні відчуваються і
в Польщі і не лише через біженців які
шукають прихистку у сусідів у місті е
шов також знаходяться інтернаціональні
солдати НАТО створило тут військову базу
для постачання зброї в Україну
рафальгеляровський фотограф літаків
останнім часом має дуже багато роботи
він бачить не бував у кількість
військових літаків у своєму місті і
зміни які він спостерігає виходять
далеко за межі їхнього аеродрому
ще одна успішна посадка
рафальгеляровський живе неподалік від
аеропорту у польському місті Ряшів
Його хобі фотографувати літаки а тут є
на що подивитися відтоді як Росія
вторглася в Україну а цей аеропорт став
хабом для міжнародної допомоги
раніше за всю історію цю аеропорту тут
сідало можливо 10 реактивних літаків
зараз Бувають дні коли 10 літаків
прилітають за день
значна частина зброї що надходить в
Україну від західних країн проходить
через цей польський аеропорт
військові літаки стоять поруч із
літаками бюджетних авіакомпаній
американські військові забезпечують
захист території аеропорту проте
ракетними установками
повідомляється що уряшові дислокується
10 тисяч солдатів НАТО
сюди прилітають літаки із України
більшість із них привозять хворих або
поранених на війні які потребують
лікування у ЄС
серед них український солдат Андрій який
летить до Іспанії щоб встановити протез
руки
серед тих хто перевозить українців які
потребують лікування парамедикиня Анна
Бублик вона каже що Ряшів відіграє
важливу роль у війні
навіть можна сказати нам важливо це
місце в даний момент для нас і тому що з
першого дня Це місто почало приймати нас
наших пацієнтів допомагати і ми дуже
вдячні польській службі і всім хто
долучився до організації того місця така
нова ситуація принесла місту економічну
вигоду особливо готелям і ресторанам
таким як ця піцерія
тут є в президент США джобайден коли
відвідував війська
відтоді до цього ресторану стало
приходити більше людей і там з'явився
новий особливий вид піци
гострий Джон містить гриби оливки
Пепероні та халапеньо
к оцінив гостроту
до початку війни в Україні Тут проживало
200 тисяч мешканців
зараз тут додатково перебувають 10 тисяч
солдатів і близько 30 тисяч біженців з
України
більшість мешканців вважають що це не
проблема але дехто занепокоєний
іноді можна побачити більше людей на
вулиці або в барах але вони не
становлять небезпеки на жаль в іншій
країні йде війна тому ми зобов'язані їх
прийняти у нас немає іншого вибору
роботи вистачає але я вважаю що ці люди
стають тягарем для нашого ринку праці
я не думаю що це добре пісня просто
стало набагато більше Можливо ми стали
відомішими в Європі ніж раніше але в
цілому все гаразд
мер конрад-фійолик також звик до нової
ролі міста
але зараз ми в центрі історії
він вже думає про післявоєнний час
сьогодні Ряшів стратегічне місто для
допомоги Україні
і ми також готуємося до того що бути
ключовим вмістом у процесі відбудови
нової України
України
але для цього війна має закінчитися тим
часом люди тут здається не бояться стати
мішеню фотограф літаків
рафальгеляровський пояснює чому
тут є американські та британські солдати
тому ми можемо почуватися цілковитій
безпеці А що тому що ми частину НАТО
незважаючи на своє хобі він був би радий
бачити менше вантажних і військових
літаків адже це означало б повернення до
миру
іспанський острів лапальма був
спустошений виверженням вулкана яке
тривало три місяці у 2021 році будинки
були зруйновані а люди змушені були
покинути свої домівки У декого з них не
залишилося дому куди можна було б
повернутися але сила вулканів не лише
руйнівна на острові лан сароте її
використовують і з користю тут
поробляють енергію а вчені граються з
вогнем заради чистої електроенергії
цей пристрій має генерувати достатню
енергії для одного сімейного
домогосподарства цілодобово
генератор працює від тепла що
піднімається зсередини вулкану
але в цій геотерміці є певні хитрощі і
команда вчених з іспанського міста
памплона збирається перевірити чи
справді їхня ідея працюватиме
це нова система на відміну від інших
вона не потребує парових турбін тому
готовий об'єкт виходить не таким
масивним
інфрачервоний термометр показує що
температура на поверхні становить від 33
до 37 градусів за Цельсієм але тут
важливо температура під землею Я
сподіваюся що там внизу під землею дуже
спекотно саме там Нам потрібно тепло і
саме звідти ми його отримаємо а тут на
горі має бути прохолодно
вулкани лансароти вже давно стали
туристичною забавкою їхні тепло дозволяє
робити цікаві трюки
[оплески]
Але чому ж воно також стати джерелом
чистої відновлюваної енергії вчені
вимірюють температуру під землею щоб
термоелектричні генератори працювали
Вона має бути набагато вищою за
температуру на поверхні
426 це температура повітря на глибині
двох метрів Що справді така температура
Так це температура повітря що виходить
звідси це має геотермічний потенціал
зараз температура 428 градусів Ми не
можемо в це повірити
ви можете відчути це але будьте обережні
пече правда Тепер ви вірите
понад 400 градусів під землею на одному
кінці І менше 40 на поверхні
перспективний результат адже пристрої
створюють потенціал напруги
використовуючи різницю температур
напівпровідника
термоелектричні генератори які ми
сконструювали дуже ефективні і
дозволяють нам спрямовувати тепло
безпосередньо в модулі і перетворювати
його на енергію
моя мотивація в тому аби зробити щось
Чого ще не існує щось нове
що Ось як ця система будь-яка енергія
яка тут виробляється екологічно чиста
Випробування тут у національному парку
Тимон Фая на лансероте матч завершені і
вчені покладають великі надії на те що
отримані дані покажуть що їхня система
яка використовує вулканічний тепло
працює
ця Енергія яку ми беремо знизу доступна
цілодобово 365 днів на рік
Ми хочемо використовувати її щоб зробити
парк самодостатнім що він більше не
потребував викопного палива
незабаром цей ресторан також може
живитися чистою енергією від нової
системи
інший Канарський острів лапальма уважно
стежить за цими експериментом
востаннє вулкан тут вивергався у 2021
році
температура у кількох метрах під семи
імпровізованими дорогами все що може
сягати 700 градусів за Цельсієм знаки
попереджають що це гаряча зона але
теоретично Вона має великий потенціал
для виробництва енергії
в університеті памплони аналізують дані
із тестового майданчика
ми могли використовувати цю систему щоб
виробляти 5 разів більше енергії ніж
сонячні електростанції цей графік
показує що енергія генерується постійно
коли різниця температур уночі
збільшується збільшується і виробництво
енергії
в церкві енергоспоживання одного будинку
домогосподарства на чотири особи
ми постійно отримуємо близько 120 Вт
підтриманий бюджетом ЄС наступне
покоління тепер буде розширено
буде побудовано більше геотермальних
електростанцій
вона опублікує результати і тоді інші
вчені зможуть прочитати їх і зробити
наступний крок або навіть більше
система яка генерує чисту енергію вдень
і вночі використовуючи різницю
температур що виникає природним чином
цей проект приносить користь ланцароте
та енергетичні революції в цілому
ми ж Бажаємо успіхів в цьому проекту А
на сьогодні усе Дякуємо за перегляд До
зустрічі в наступному випуску програми У
фокусі Європа
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]